-Welcome to the show!
-How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
-This is so exciting.
-It's very nice to see you
We've known each other
for a very long time.
-Very long time.
-Yet I've never met
your parents.
I met your dad backstage.
-My dad is backstage.
He's watching right now.
-Very exciting and yet --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, you can cheer
for the idea of fathers.
You can cheer for the idea
of what fathers are.
-Your mother, noticeably absent.
-Yeah, can I tell you why?
-Yeah.
-She's very supportive.
Let me start this story
by saying she's very supportive.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There's a live podcast taping
with the lead guy
from "Outlander"?
-Yeah --
-His name is Sam Heughan.
-Yeah.
-He's very attractive.
-I mean, unless --
I mean, very --
And if I could pop my
very Jewish nose, you can see --
-There's a difference.
-There's a difference, Seth.
You know what I mean?
So, there's a live podcast
and I said, "Oh, it's at
the same time that we're filming
Seth. What do you want to do?"
and she goes, "Oh, um, I can
just watch you on TV, right?
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Yeah, I guess."
So, right now she's literall
watching this guy
instead of here.
[ Laughter ]
-But she is -- She would -
Normally, she would be
at a show you were doing.
-She's the most supportive
We did --
I do long-form improv,
which is where you came from
and we played Carnegie Hall,
me and Thomas Middleditch,
who's been on this show.
-Yep.
-Whoo!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
and so she went
into Carnegie Hall.
She pretended she was, like,
the captain of Carnegie Hall
like, welcoming everybody
to my show.
Like, she's the most supportive,
but nothing's going
to beat that.
That's the most beautiful ma
in the world.
[ Laughter ]
-And you and Middleditch -
Your long-form improv show
is gonna be on Netflix,
which is very exciting.
-It is!
Yeah, we're doing -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's so cool.
-And by the way,
you know how terrifying that is,
the idea of filming
long-form improv,
'cause you have no idea
what the shows are going to be
-Thrilling to watch
in the theater.
-Yes.
-And the idea of trying to
I think, capture it on fil
is a high level of difficulty.
-It is that.
-I cannot wait.
-We are going to release three
at the same time.
So, it's going be a series
of specials on Netflix,
and I'm so excited
because it will be great
to show people who have neve
seen long-form before,
something that you and I
have been doing for decade
to people who have never
seen it before.
-You were an intern when I first
met you at UCB Theater.
And you found a picture
you took of me in 2004.
-I took a picture of Seth
when I was an intern.
-Look at me. There's 2004,
walking down a hallway.
Back when I wore a leather
jacket
and, like, a European skiing
helmet, yeah.
-Did you just get off -- You
just got off your motorcycle
-I just got off my motorcycle.
I think that I'm like,
that's like, somebody said like,
"Pretend like you're walking."
'Cause I don't --
It feels like I'm acting.
-You're very comfortable
in front of the camera.
It looks --
-Somebody just --
I believe it was
the five-year anniversary
and somebody was just talkin
about, you and Adam Pally,
who is a longtime friend.
-Oh, sure, yes, yes.
-I believe it was around
five years, right?
-It could be, yeah.
-So, there was a week
where people, different people
were doing one episode
of "The Late Late Show" on CBS
-Yes, it was right after
Craig Ferguson had left,
but right before James Corden.
-James Corden.
-What are we gonna do?
-What are they going to do
to fill the time?
-Yeah.
-And so they let Adam Pally host
an episode
of the "Late Late Show."
And you joined him
as his sidekick.
-I did.
-And you guys did
a late night show
on the "CBS This Morning" set.
-We did, at Charlie Rose's
studio with zero audience.
-Yeah.
-And it was during a blizzar
so none of the real -- I think a
lot of the guests had to cancel.
-Yeah.
-And it was just a mess.
It was a mess.
-It is,
and I really recommend tryin
to track it down online --
-They take it off everywhere
-Did they? It doesn't exist?
-Anytime someone puts it
on the Internet, someone's like,
no, no, nobody can see this,
and they take it off.
-Well, let's take a look
'cause we found a little bit
-That'd be great. Great.
-With me as never before
is my good friend
and comedy collaborator
for over 10 years, Ben Schwartz.
-How are you, Adam?
-Now, Schwartz, you are the star
of "House of Lies."
-That is on Sundays
at 10:00 p.m. on Showtime.
Do we have a clip?
-Nope.
-Cool.
-You're a guest star
on "Parks and Recreation."
-I play Jean-Ralphio. Yeah
it's actually the final season
Why don't we roll that clip?
-If I didn't have the first one,
why would I have the second?
-Copy that.
-And that was it.
[ Laughter ]
-That was basically it.
-It was basically if --
It was basically like
Adam and I got the opportunity
to just do a show
just for ourselves.
-Yeah.
-And by mistake,
somebody aired it live
across the world.
-Yeah, and not, like,
on public access. On CBS.
-Oh, on CBS.
-Like, that's
the funniest thing about i
when you watch it, it's --
-I love that you know about it
-It's the best -- It was -
When I found out about it,
it's really -- I truly --
People have to do some digging
but it's worth tracking down
-It's become a cult thing
where, like, people try --
Yeah, 'cause
you have to find it.
It's like the search
for Curly's gold to start.
That is a "City Slickers II"
reference.
-Yeah.
-But then when you find it
it is just for 55 minutes, it'
just two little boys having fun.
-Yeah.
-And I do want to ask,
'cause we talked
about Pally, Middleditch,
and some other people
you improvise with.
Where's the worst place
you ever did improv?
-Oh, we -- One time,
there was this music festival,
and me, Gil Ozeri, who is one of
the funniest people of all time,
I believe Jackie Clark, as well,
we were the comedy
in between the music acts,
and I'll tell you
what college students do not
want to see between music acts
is three improvisers
going onstage.
And then at the very end,
literally, the big act,
whoever it was, it was everybody
waiting for hours and hour
to be at the front of the line
and then we had
to tell the audience
that that person actually
is going to be performing
in a venue inside.
So whoever waited all that tim
in the front row
is now going to have the worst
seat when they go inside.
And it was like fraternity rag
like I've never seen,
foaming at the mouth and, like
their Bob Marley black light
posters ripping to shreds.
It was ludicr-- It was insane.
-It's very nice you went
from that to Carnegie Hall
Well deserved.
-Oh, thanks, man.
-And thank you so much
for being here.
-I'm so excited to be here
You've always been
so kind to me.
I appreciate it, Seth.
Thank you, sir.
-Ben Schwartz, everybody!